monsieur marché l'humanité de ce matin
publie un communiqué du bureau politique
du parti communiste qui est un soutien
mouvement revendicatif et dans ce
communiqué je lis la phrase suivante le
mécontentement actuel des travailleurs
je cite ne pourra trouver de solutions
réelles et durables que par des
changements démocratiques décisif lors
que veut dire exactement cette phrase
cette phrase veut dire que les
travailleurs
ne peuvent pas se contenter de lutter
pour la satisfaction de leurs
revendications économiques et sociales
s'ils veulent obtenir des changements
réels et durables ils doivent s'en
prendre au régime qui est responsable de
la situation et lutter pour remplacer ce
pouvoir qui est le pouvoir des grands
monopoles capitalistes par un régime
démocratique nouveau
concrètement alors le parti est disposé
à aller jusqu'où pour appuyer les
travailleurs dans le sens que vous
souhaitez c'est à dire du changement de
pouvoir
pour le moment nous sommes décidés à
aller jusqu'où nous sommes décidés à
soutenir je répète les luttes en cours
pour la satisfaction des revendications
pour ce qui concerne un changement de
régime et de politique nous avons
toujours dit qu'il fallait mobiliser les
plus larges masses des plus larges
couches sociales autour de la classe
ouvrière qui a le plus grand intérêt un
changement de régime politique par
conséquent il ne s'agit pas pour nous
comme voudrait d'ailleurs le faire
croire monsieur chaban delmas
d'imposer un changement de régime par la
subversion absolument pas notre parti
travail et continuera de travailler à
gagner l'immense majorité des
travailleurs des masses populaires à
l'idée qu'il faut remplacer le pouvoir
des monopoles par une démocratie
nouvelle impulsion dans la légalité
révolution dans la légalité qu'est ce
que vous entendez par évolution
égalité nous ne nous ne venons pas je
répète nous ne menons pas une entreprise
de subversion
nous voulons changer de régime par la
volonté de la majorité de notre peuple
et c'est à cela que nous travaillons